I've gotten several nicknames one of the
biggest ones that stick out in my mind
was one run Anderson I would run one
time but I'm gonna tell you right now
you better have your camera's ready
because it was going to be one big bad
run I'm Dennis Anderson and I'm the
original grave digger
if you don't know what a monster-truck
is it's because you're a concrete
cruising city slicker the definition of
a monster-truck is and has to have a
6643 tara tyre meaning sixty six inches
tall 43 inches wide and normally they're
around 10 to 12 foot tall and 12 foot
wide and they usually weigh about ten to
twelve thousand pounds that's what a
monster truck is my goal in life as a
kid growing up is I wanted to be this
big farmer it never really was a goal in
life for me to be a pro Monster Jam
truck driver
the whole legacy of gravedigger this
right here was the first stepping stone
my goal in life as I was building this
truck was to have a big nice shop with a
concrete floor because I built this
thing in a tin chicken house
I call it my empire and it's the
gravedigger Empire here now we up to
nine grave diggers we've built 32 grave
digger trucks in the last 34 years this
is the dyno room my most favorite place
on the property 1,500 horsepower and
we're going to see a test pool right now
yeah baby trust me I have paid my dues
all the way down the line
I have fractured my back I've broke my
shoulder I've broke my ribs I broke my
nose a couple of times I've broke my
arms when you talk about living a dream
that's this old guy right here I never
have grown up
I still love toys and that's why I
gravedigger is what it is today